good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's
integrated translation
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the
school of data science and by a grant
from the national institutes of general
medical sciences
uh it is my delight today to welcome our
friend and colleague
dr neda jahanshad from the university of
southern california
in los angeles california neda johnson
is an associate professor of neurology
at the imaging genetic center which is
part of the stevens neuroimaging
and informatics institute at the
university of southern california
she holds undergraduate degrees from
johns hopkins university
and her phd from the university of
california los angeles
dr jahan shot has over 10 years of
experience in analyzing brain scans from
large groups of individuals and
comparing magnetic resonance imaging
scans of people
with and without brain disorders of all
ages
much of her research explores the brain
as a network of interconnected pathways
using diffusion weighted
a technology which reveals physical
connections between different
functional areas of the brain dr jahan
shot also directs the laboratory of
brain e sciences
at usc loebs as it is called is a
collaborative multidisciplinary team
which combines multimodal brain imaging
techniques with advanced computational
modeling approaches
and information sciences to better
understand the brain and reliably
identify risk factors which contribute
to its decline in
aging the lab aims to ensure that their
tools and approaches and findings
bridge international boundaries for
broadest possible applications
dr john honchot is a key developer for
the enigma consortium
which brings together hundreds of
researchers from around the planet
these researchers work together to
identify the genetic environmental risk
factors
which make the brain susceptible to
disease dr jahan shot's presentation
today is entitled advancing neuroimaging
genomics with continuous team
science and as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording by
youtube and if you are watching by
youtube today thank you so much for
joining us
also our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are strongly encouraged to submit any
questions for dr jahan shot via the chat
feature in their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
i'll ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and so neda thank you so much
for doing us the favor of presenting
your work today and we are excited to
hear your presentation
thank you so much dr van horn um i'm
excited to be here
i'm just going to turn off my video so
it's easier for me to give the
presentation and i'll turn it back on
for questions um well
thanks everyone as dr van horn mentioned
my talk today is
is called advancing neuroimaging
genomics with continuous team science
um uh i have some nih funding and
funding from
biogen that's unrelated to the contents
of this talk
so as i'm sure you're all well aware
now especially towards the end of this
seminar series
there has been a replication crisis
in um brain imaging
sorry uh hopefully that i should silence
my phone next time
um so what
does that um where does that come from
so
just a little bit of background most of
the neuroimaging studies that
sort of culminated in this replication
crisis
a lot of them had been in very small
sample sizes
or and now we're seeing as uh relatively
small
between 20 maybe 200. and they were only
conducted within single studies without
independent replications
and some of them didn't even address
multiple testing issues
well so when going back and trying to
rerun a lot of these tests or trying to
replicate these results
claims in many papers did not hold
in addition to some of these technical
issues um there's a publication bias
that that
often prevents null or contradictory
findings from being reported
so there's a potential inflation of
effect sizes
in these literature-based meta-analyses
where you're really just pulling
together
findings that were significant or
successful
now it's obviously
one of the reasons behind the small
sample sizes
is because at least in brain imaging
scanning is pretty expensive it's
approximately 600 dollars an hour just
for the scan alone
and you need often times about an hour
per subject
so there have been several initiatives
over
um the last um
almost two decades now where
their are multi-center
initiatives that that aim to um
coordinate data collection across many
sites and ensure well-powered studies
and this involves some prospective data
harmonization efforts let's say
like imaging phantoms
um and ensuring that the protocols
across the sites are are the same
these are all exceptional resources for
scientific
discovery
but on on the other hand what happens to
all the data that
was not from these multi-million dollar
multi-center initiatives all of all the
studies that were
uh collected before all those smaller
individual studies
so at the time a lot of
people were actually being funded to
study some of the same questions in
regards to brain development
psychiatric disorders aging dementia
oftentimes in different
population and
everyone would have their own protocols
and and
imaging protocols or maybe different
functional tasks
so um the
one idea is is can all these individual
smaller studies
that were funded to do the same ultimate
analysis
can they be merged for for more powerful
reliable findings
um and could they be merged with each
other
or with these newer multi-site
initiatives and how
um so that's sort of the basis behind
the enigma consortium which i'm a part
of
so enigma stands for
enhancing neuroimaging genetics through
meta-analysis
and i'll get through why uh this acronym
is um not exactly what we do anymore
um so enigma started with
um the idea of uh of genetics
um and especially because neuroimaging
genetics in particular
were very susceptible to false positives
um and uh you could say well why is that
the case we've had
these neuroimaging genetic studies for
you know
two decades now um
uh so we we know some of these candidate
genes
so i've just here taken a snapshot of uh
some some papers and this is not to call
anyone out if if they've been involved
in these papers some of them
i i've been involved in it's just at the
time
um we thought we knew a risk factor
for um for brain decline
so but but we actually hadn't double
checked
there a lot of them had weak or no
statistical correlations there was a
lack of replication lack of power
and if you do a power analysis you need
800 people to detect a one percent
effect
and this is um a very big effect for
uh for a snip or a single nucleotide
variant or genetic marker um with 80
power at p less than 105 0.05 sorry
uh so if if snips explain just
one percent or less than one percent
then why
are these imaging um genetic studies
being done in less than a hundred people
um and that was because
we were doing underpowered candidate
neuroimaging genetic studies so we will
see that a lot of these
um were in
about 100 or less participants
and sometimes they would even
test multiple factors but not correct
for them so
if you're testing um five domains
you should correct for uh five tests
so we'll see why there was this
um this sort of push towards uh
or this decline towards the crisis
because
we weren't looking at things properly
so enigma began in 2009
initially to identify genetic loci that
reliably contribute to brain structure
and
the reason we focused on this genetic
aspect
is because genetics offer this direct
link to the underlying
biological mechanism which which means
that there are
there are easy targets for um for
treatment um and at the same time you
have the imaging marker
for monitoring and assessing the
efficacy of any treatment
um and so
it's it's it's important to to keep in
mind
that when you're scanning the genome you
actually have
about a million independent common
variants so you're not just doing one
test
you're doing a million tests so you need
to correct for those
million tests and set your
significance threshold appropriately and
that would be
5 times 10 to the negative 8 for a
single genome-wide association study
and it's important to keep in mind that
your power doesn't depend on the
the test that you're doing so yeah an
ri is more expensive to collect than
let's say some
classifying someone is having a disease
or not
um but it's not more powerful so you'll
you still need the sample size
uh and to illustrate that
this uh this paper looks at the number
of subjects
needed for a given number of tests uh
with respect to the percent variance
explained and as i mentioned
a single nucleotide uh genetic marker
often has
less than one percent uh variance
explained
um oops this got moved so um
we what we would have is actually um
around here if we're doing um
a 10 times 10 to the n to the sixth test
uh the brain should actually be around
here so we have about
um at least 10 000 individuals that we
would need
for a successful genome wide association
test to have the power for it
um but how are we going to get 10 000
scans
uh well uh we'll we as i mentioned we're
going to try and pull
this data from all the all the smaller
studies from around the world
and as i'm sure you're aware uh
a a person scanned in one scanner is not
going to
have the same exact mri image as
that same person scanned in another
scanner so this is a
an example of one person scanned at a
1.5
t scanner and then again at a three
tesla scanner so you can see
um if you're familiar with looking at
brains
you might know you could probably guess
that this is the same person
but you can clearly see that the brain
structure is
uh has different contrasts so like the
gray and white matter contrasts are
different some structures are easier to
see than others
um so we have these these
um these issues that we're trying to
work through uh
and our first approach is this
analytical harmonization
so um uh
we might want to actually uh embrace
this variability
in in the in the acquisition you're not
going to necessarily want to
have your finding depend on a given
scanner if you're trying to develop
a medication or trying to monitor um
brain tissue atrophy you don't want that
quantity to have to depend on a single
skin or otherwise everyone in the world
who might have
a disorder related to your treatment or
the biomarker would have to go to a
particular location and
we know how difficult that could that
could be
so so what we decided to do is just to
try and embrace that variability and
harmonize the analysis plan instead
so kind of um select certain metrics to
analyze
uh the same across everyone
ensure that quality assurance is done
similarly across sites and have the same
statistical workflow and this works
exceptionally well for
this coordinated meta analysis that we
did
and to to pool all this data we want to
ensure that the metrics that we're
extracting uh the brain metrics
are derived reliably from scans
regardless of how they are required
again we're trying to embrace this
variability so
but we do want to make sure that
whatever measures we're extracting
are reliable um uh regardless of
uh of the scanner um so
before we distribute our protocols and
um
let people know what what measures we're
trying to extract
we need to test those measures um are
those measures
extracted reliably and are they reliably
reliable
and by that i mean again does it depend
on a single scanner or can we reliably
extract this measure
across different scanners and
we'll have often four or five sites
beta test any protocols make sure that
everything works if there are
any frequently asked questions we'll
make note of that and try and
troubleshoot
it and improve our protocols
and once the quality assurance measures
are in place then we can send them out
so one tool to start with
many imaging uh many many
brain imaging sites around the world are
familiar with
these common uh tools such as free
surfer
for cortical analyses so um before
we we say hi everyone runfreesurfer we
make sure
to test whether they're they're they the
measures we're looking at are reliable
so is there high inter-class correlation
so if you do a test re-test analysis at
different
uh scanning sites um is it reliable
regardless and do we have
quality control protocols um and then
so we put that into place so uh ways
that
individuals can look for errors in the
outcome like make sure the whole cortex
is extracted
so we have created cortical quality
control protocols
that we've also distributed alongside
the analysis plan so we have um
several imaging protocols um
the first one i mentioned is based on on
free surfer
but there are other ones based on
diffusion tensor imaging
or more detailed analyses of shape we
recently a
group in germany that we work closely
with has developed
a harmonized analysis of fmri
processing which could be used for
resting state and also for
task-based fmri
so going back into that the the free
surfer
protocols i'm going to go through and
it's a recent example of how we
um we use this and to pool all the data
so um the latest genome-wide association
study we did
was entitled the genetic architecture of
the human cortex
and it was published in science last
year
so we asked the question can we identify
these genetic variants that are
associated with just normal variation in
portable surface area thickness
as a whole and also these regional
patterns
so at each site um we ran
the geoass of cortical structure so
again
we're making use of the not only the the
data sets at each site but also the
computational infrastructure so we're
doing this distributed
analysis where each site
does the statistical analysis does all
the computation
and then the results are all pulled
together
so once all the sites have
done the analysis they send only their
results not the images
or the genetics themselves um to a
centralized location where we do the
meta-analysis
and we do some quality control uh tests
on top of that and then
once we pull all the data together and
make sure that there are no quality
issues
we found over 200 genetic
regions that are associated with
um either one trait surface area or
thickness or those traits in particular
regions
and we found that actually most loci
were unique
to a particular brain or trait so we do
see this regional patterning
of effects we saw that
the the cortical um
uh the genetic architecture of the
cortical measures are actually
pretty different so surface area um was
a little bit different than
thickness with
with surface area finding several more
regions of genetic association
and within surface area actually we see
this regional patterning
where we found a lot more
genetic associations with areas of the
occipital lobe than some of the other
regions
so we have this polygenic polygenicity
of
the occipital lobe where there are more
uh genes
associated with that or genetic loci
um and you can actually take the full
genome-wide results so not looking at
the significant loci only but really the
across all a million independent regions
and
correlate those with genetic results of
other traits and we actually see
a positive correlation between as you
might expect
greater surface area and greater
educational attainment and this is a
genetic correlation
and also a negative correlation between
traits
such as adhd and insomnia where
lower surface area correlates
or genetic risk for lower surface area
correlates with genetic risk for adhd
and insomnia
and interestingly there's a positive
correlation with
with parkinson's disease where um
genetic risk for higher surface area
also correlates with genetic risk for
increased risk of parkinson's
so this reproducibility is actually an
issue across
these biomedical fields um not just
genetics
and our our goal is not to just focus
on genetics but to ensure that this will
recruit disability is something that we
can
evaluate across all of the neuro imaging
sciences
so we extend these methods um
far beyond genetics to look at a series
of
disorders diseases
and various conditions even
in normal
normal development and and healthy
individuals
so um we are
uh using these these protocols that are
are similar across these working groups
so
the same quality control protocols the
same analyses
we are able to take the results and
compare them to each other so you get
this interesting
overview of how different disorders for
example might
um have different effects on the brain
and these are all
conducted using similar protocols and
each one of these analyses had
over a thousand participants
um and as i mentioned it's not our work
is
not just limited to free surfer and
cortical
uh surface area or thickness but we've
also done some work with
diffusion tensor imaging um
we're not only looking for um
reliable effects across the uh
the data that we're we're using um
but this was a an interesting
application where after we published
this paper
uh with i think over over 30 sites
participating and finding
globally uh reduced or lower fa
in schizophrenia participants versus
controls
a separate consortium a separate
multi-site consortium
with only japanese sites found very
similar results
and we were able to look at these side
by side
and the the other consortium
also used exactly the same imaging
protocols which we had made public
so um that's
kind of a brief overview of a lot of the
uh enigma work but there's plenty more
so if you're
interested in any of um
the conditions or disorders or studying
any of the traits that that
you saw in that plot do reach out
because there's always room
um for additional analyses and that sort
of gets into my next
uh aspect of
how we're extending some of these work
and and that's
to look at really the continuous portion
of this
um as i mentioned each
you know every time we're presenting
work on
enigma there might be someone who um
has a data set that they would like to
contribute to the
these ongoing analyses so we have this
um
continuous analysis uh sort of
um where
as more and more groups are joining our
sample size is growing
and and with greater sample size you
have more power
to detect effects sometimes you can
detect uh sort of the same effect
but with more power so this is an
example of our first
study looking at
doing a genome-wide association for
hippocampal volume
we had about 8 000 individual
scans across all the data sets
and this was our top hit was just below
the significance threshold in a second
analysis there were um 5 000
more scans that were have been
contributed from
many sites around the world and that top
hit was now past that significant
threshold and was significant
and very recently um the data
uh the sample size doubled and you can
see this this evolution of significance
um in these findings as we're continuing
these analyses
a lot of them have are repeated
um you're you're seeing this sort of
evolution in results
and not all of them are in this
direction
sometimes you'll see a result that might
have
gone away once more samples were added
so it's important to have this
this um evolution of knowledge and that
refining our understanding of um
of these tests that we're doing so um
we're developing this sort of
infrastructure to accommodate for
these continuous analyses as there's
more and more data being held
being contributed or even collected
um can we do what we're doing
in a continuous manner um
sort of automatically actually so can we
um so we're working with
researchers at the information sciences
institute at usc
to develop this sort of workflow and
just to
give you a little bit of background so
this is a new
infrastructure that we're calling
neurodisk and
there's a website that
will be made public very soon we
ask a hypothesis which is a question
that we want to
to test and this is linked with a line
of inquiry
that will look for data in
this wiki that we've developed
um and the the wiki has
certain properties uh it has a given
ontology and
the data sets are uh annotated to
include um features for for knowing
whether
uh or not that data set would be
included
in a particular hypothesis and
and so we can look for data that would
match our hypothesis
and then we have um workflows let's see
analyses statistical analyses um
in a separate system that gets called
and all that together allows us to
continuously update our our um
our knowledge so here's an example let's
ask a hypothesis
um this is based on the results of the
um
cortical genetics paper that i that i
mentioned so
let's let's ask for example is the
effect size
of um this genetic variant which was
actually our
top genetic variant on the surface area
of the precentral cortex
is it associated with age
so that triggers this line of inquiry
which which says okay we're looking for
the effect size of a particular genotype
on a certain
brain imaging trait and we're looking to
see if that's associated with the
demographic
which in our case would be age so that
triggers
a lookup of our
wiki so our meta wiki where we have all
the annotations
um and as and also the um
the statistical uh analysis gets run
with all the data that it finds
and so this um this allows
this sort of continuous evolution so if
uh you missed your chance to participate
in a study that was published
you could we have the protocols in place
um
in terms of the imaging protocol so you
know to run those
uh you have the statistical protocols
also which
are made public um and those results can
get integrated
even if the data doesn't get shared
through
and by the data i mean the individual
subject level data which is often
um uh sometimes shareable sometimes not
so we
we work under the assumption that it
doesn't always need to be shared
at the individual subject level so even
if that is not the case you could still
contribute results
and be a part of this continued workflow
um and as an example
uh we uh we ran the
the results of our um again cortical
uh genetic paper um with and without
uh the largest sample that we had which
was the uk biobank
um so if uh that data set got
added in later um we have an evolution
of the results so these are the forest
plots which show each individual cohort
that participated
and then after we add the uk biobank
you see this additional
row here and in
our our um example of looking at the
association with
age uh or mean age of the cohort we plot
uh mean age on the x-axis and the effect
size
the y-axis and you see uh the trend line
sort of evolve after the addition of new
data sets
so we also have
other extensions and initiatives um
including uh statistical and image
harmonization
for uh beyond meta-analysis so if you
can share
the individual subject level data um
you know what what can we do so um
beyond uh meta analysis and that that's
exactly what i mean basically you're no
longer meta analyzing statistical
results
from individual groups but you have
individual
subject level data from all sites and
you have
essentially a mega analysis where all
the data are
um can be joined and you can look
for um uh
it actually allows to look for
more than um
for let's say rarer uh occurrences so in
this case
um in this epilepsy
diffusion paper that we published in
brain
last year um the
the individual subject level
diffusion measures were all pooled to
look for
effects of subtypes of epilepsy
and some of these subtypes are not as
common
as others so you would not you might get
let's say three or four individuals
within a particular cohort that have
this subtype
but when you're in in that three or four
is certainly not enough to do such a
well-powered statistical test
uh even if it will be cooled with with
other data later
um or other effect science later so
by pulling these rare subtypes
together in one big cohort then you can
do
a more powerful test um and
um you uh have
to in some sense harmonize the the data
sets to
account for the scanner variability that
we talked about earlier
um so in this case we did a statistical
harmonization
um where if you can see here
before the harmonization
the distribution for each site is a
different color in this plot
and you see how they're basically all
over the place
for um fa yet every site has its own
distribution and um for those familiar
with diffusion
imaging you know that that makes perfect
sense because
these values are are essentially
only dependent on on the the acquisition
of the image
so after this this combat statistical
correction
uh we see that all the the data sites um
all the sites have their data
distributions
um where with similar means and variants
um so that's how we were able to to do
these analyses
um and adjust for the side effects
um so as i uh
explained um the meta analysis
is where the stats are run at the
individual sites and the results are
merged
um and it does allow for the subject
level data to remain
local so if it cannot be shared um
then then then that's fine um and then
on the other hand the mega analysis the
the subject level data
are pulled together and then the
analysis is run on the cohort or the
huge
data sample as a whole um
so we are harmonization is actually a
very active
area of study um
this is another example of how
statistical harmonization can be used we
have a paper out on that archive looking
at different stages of parkinson's
disease and
again um not all cohorts collect
uh you know um or are looking at
um uh parkinson's patients or or
people with parkinson's at all these
different stages
so you might have um lower frequency of
certain stages at certain sites
and by pulling all the data and doing
harmonization trying to account for
for these site effects we're able to
focus our statistical analyses on
these subgroups of individuals
at different homeowner stages um
but harmonization is actually a very
active area of study
and there are um some deep learning
methods that are now being
uh used to try and uh
remove the sight effect um
so one uh one
area that we've been working on uh
maintain lou in my group
um has this new uh method based
on stargans ii where
uh each
uh if you see here the the static images
um represent uh the
original uh image at the top row
um and then the bottom row represents
um the that same subject
image harmonized to a another
scan um so what you're seeing kind of
move up here this is what we're
harmonizing to we're trying to match
the um style of
um these things any other image
so you can you can see that the
contrast uh changes but we're not
adjusting
structure at all so you it should still
be
the same individual but perhaps look
like it was scanned at a different
scanner
another approach could be this is
again another active area of study
whether we can derive acquisition
invariant
imaging traits so um
if you were to extract the midsagittal
corpus callosum from
from individual scandal different
scanners the thickness
might be very dependent on the voxel
size
of the image but but
the the curvature
might be something that you could
extract reliably
um across scans so this is something
we're actively working on
in my group uh alyssa sue has um
published uh a sifying paper a couple
years ago and now we have
a deep learning approach for this
extraction
and uh deriving these um
these measures of of curvature um
we're also working on on
better methods for extracting
information from diffusion imaging as
well
and italianeer in my group showed that
fractional and isotropy or fa derived
from the tensor distribution function
which
essentially is um looking at
all the possible tensors that you can
fit to a given voxel instead of the best
one which is usually done with the
standard dti
but that actually gives a more uh
homogeneous
distribution across sites than
um than the standard fa alone so
that was that was interesting as well
and
uh all this um all this harmonization
and all this
like um ensuring
common uh
protocols and statistical approaches and
quality control
measures across sites also allows us to
ask
questions across um across these groups
that maybe we couldn't
equate we couldn't ask before
so one uh one nice thing about this
is that it does open the door for
looking at
um cross disorder or or trans diagnostic
effects so
um if there are symptoms or outcomes
that are similar across
different conditions or disorders
maybe we could look across those and
not have a disorder specific
analysis that we're doing so um suicidal
thoughts and behaviors are common across
many mental illnesses um and we are
uh using this these statistical and
image harmonization efforts to address
um address this and pull the data
together and account for the fact that
there are um uh
there's a low base rate of suicide
attempts
in a given collected cohort so
even though it's rare it's obviously a
very big problem so
we need these harmonization methods to
be able to pull the data
to be able to ask these questions and
have the power
to answer the questions reliably so this
is
one initiative that we're currently
working on is the enigma suicidal
thoughts and behaviors
group which again is not limited to a
particular
disease or disorder but is trying to
look across
all of them to to be able to identify
the
neurobiological signatures of
suicidal traits and other
factors that might associate with those
so right now we have been able to look
across various disorders including
schizophrenia bipolar
a major depression we do have some ocd
and ptsd participants as well
and we're not just comparing individuals
who've
had suicidal attempts with healthy
controls but now we have clinical
controls
where these are individuals that have
the same
diagnoses but
might not have made a suicide attempt or
do not have suicidal ideations
so this is an active area of work
and um
i i won't present the results because
these are being uh
updated regularly so in summary
uh sort of this this international
multi-site collaboration that we're
doing
has really
given us an opportunity to work in a
well-powered
environment for for neuroscience with
uh computational efficiency especially
if
for the meta analysis studies where you
have
the computation being done in a
distributed manner
and also um is
an opportunity to to really look um
at this open science and sharing of
information and to
to collaborate to ensure reproducibility
and get these well-powered results
and that and of course that's that's
related to the team science as well
and and in in recent years it's really
been um opened up
new i think technical questions as well
how do we best harmonize the data
and how do we advance um neuroscientific
discovery uh so um
there are hundreds of
people in enigma and i
would want to thank them all but i
don't think you want to sit through that
so i
will refer you to this this
recent review paper if you're interested
in learning more
this is published in translational
psychiatry where it describes the last
10 years of our work in enigma
and thank you to the the lab members
and to the folks whose results i i did
present
today and thanks and with that i'm happy
to answer
any questions thank you so much for
summarizing uh enigma for us and
uh for and all the work that you guys
have been doing
um through enigma it's a a fine example
of team science writ large uh around the
planet it's a
really a great um
kind of group resource uh this is a
great example of that uh
kind of done at uh at scale if you will
um i like the idea of
you know you can touching on the notion
of publication bias this is something
i've looked at myself
um where you know we've been we've had
this as a problem
in neuroimaging for since its inception
where
you know i can remember the early days
of neural imaging
and the certain software packages who
will remain nameless where they hard
coded the number of subjects that you
are permitted to use
uh in their software at n equals six
and you know when you were trying to do
this uh the the
the groups that would use the software
uh to you know for software like that
with these small sample sizes
you know they were just very prolific so
they're flooding the literature with
these small
uh sample sizes and of course they're
only reporting on the stuff that was
statistically significant so early on we
came out of the shoot with a publication
bias problem
um and it's interesting to see enigma
taking this
really kind of global planetary if you
will
approach to uh bringing people together
around this i have a couple of questions
one of them is are there have you
noticed any site-based
differences you know i know that the
whole effort is to kind of
grab all the data and pool it into one
big sample but i'm also kind of curious
about do you see
say country by country based differences
uh you know site by site
you know are those evidence and how do
you adjust for them
there are huge differences um and uh one
example
i think that that
sticks out in my mind is this recent
work that we published earlier this year
on our hiv collaboration
so um we have many sites
in the u.s we have a couple or one site
in
europe and
ascent most of the us-based sites were
or majority male uh so
um between i'd say
70 to 100 of
the participants at each in the
individual u.s sites were male
and we also had a cohort in south africa
and um that one was largely female that
was the only one that was largely female
so so we see these these
these differences that are not only
based
on um the imaging acquisition of these
different sites but the recruitment
uh and i think that is um
an important thing to be aware of in
these harmonization approaches because a
lot of the harmonization approaches
attempt to statistically match the
distributions but maybe they're not
meant to be statistically matched maybe
there are biological
differences in these cohorts that should
be taken into account
so this is a very good question because
it's a it's an open area of research and
it's a challenge that we're facing is
a lot of times we we might you know we
might ask what a proportion of
um the cohort is male or female but
there might be information that we don't
ask and we don't know about but there
are clear differences between
um like ethnic groups or countries or
just
the so yeah it's how do we put
the things i think that i mean it's such
an interesting thing because
with the the way in which enigma has
approached this which is you know
laudable because it's clearly been very
productive
in a maybe a more traditional
literature-based meta-analysis where
you're gathering
you know trying to estimate effect sizes
from particular studies in a literature
um you can also incorporate the study
kind of factors that went into the
contra the creation of that effect size
right the end result
and it could be diagnostic criteria
differences it could for
mri it could be trte differences or
contrast related differences
it could be things like the you know the
proportion of males and females in the
sample as you point out
um in a meta-analyses i've done these
are somewhat dated now but
um they we found a statistical
correlation between the urine the size
of the effect and the year in which the
study was done
and apparently in the example i did ages
ago
apparently this is a common thing that
the early effect sizes tend to be larger
and as you get better at doing those
studies
and you incorporate more controls to
them that the effect sizes get smaller
uh one additional thing which was kind
of ironic i suppose from an enigma point
of view is that
we found that uh the size of the effect
was also inversely correlated with the
number of authors on the paper
we thought was kind of interesting from
a from a sociology of science point of
view but
anyway it would be very interesting to
explore some of those
study factors because you may have like
you know country by country
differences in for example how
parkinson's is defined or how
alzheimer's is diagnosed or what have
you
absolutely um i i agree there are
certainly
differences but at the same time um
you know you know one of the things
we're trying to do is embrace those
differences we're not trying to solve
um oh absolutely in one location only
you know
absolutely i mean you know hopefully
these things are you know
they're random enough that you can
average over them and uh and
be able to to do okay um one of the
things which i
just correct me if i'm wrong but that um
the genome white association work that
you're doing
is is that's largely snip based upon
snips
um snip related uh genomics um is there
any opportunity
for enigma to adapt to more full genome
sequence
technologies as they become more readily
available so there are there are efforts
looking
at um rare variants for example and then
or or copy number variants or
um like 22q deletion is its own working
group
so we do have efforts outside of just
the full genome
wide screen whole genome to
to really make the most of of that
entire genome screening um you would
and look across across an unbiased way
we do not have the sample sizes in
neuroimaging to do that yet
yeah there might be ways as i mentioned
to kind of look
um at you know maybe
use the whole genome to look at regions
around
common variants that we found
significant to look for causal
loci or or really sort of
pinpoint some of the genetic
factors but in terms of screening whole
genome um
i'm not sure if if uh there are fields
that aren't there yet even not just yet
that's the next grant you mentioned um
you mentioned the word uh commonalities
which is kind of interesting
i'm curious if you guys have um a lot of
the analyses and all the working groups
you know they seem to be very
disease specific and i think you sort of
hinted at this in part of your uh
presentation
about trying to do it irrespective of
disease
and look for say commonalities across
these different diagnostic
um distinctions to see if you can't
almost like anneal different disease
kind of uh
profiles into more common ones does that
make sense
you know what i mean um where for
example two diseases may be somewhat
similar
so similar enough that their
distributions overlap in some
way and i was just curious if you guys
have attempted to do anything like that
yeah there so there are some uh
a lot more cross-diagnostic work now
and sort of trans-diagnostic as i
mentioned with suicidal ideation
and attempt work but there are efforts
to
to try and look at symptom profiles
across different disorders like there's
there's currently an effort
um to
pull the data from groups that have
studied
uh depression or major depression
bipolar and schizophrenia into
one and kind and look for um effects of
let's say
antidepressants across across these
individuals or look for
common profiles look for what
distinguishes
a bipolar from major depression in terms
of brain circuitry and and
there are current efforts that have
really over the last like year or two
really taken
off once the sample size were
large enough to work with what um
clearly enigma is doing a great job at
identifying these effects
and linking things to um particular gene
profiles
um and obviously the sample size just
keeps getting larger
um is enigma um
the results from enigma these results of
these studies do you know
if any of the studies are being used to
inform clinical treatments for any of
these disorders
that's a really good question i think
there are efforts to try and get there
um a lot of our first sets of papers
were really
to establish that this data could even
be pulled together and that we can
look for these common trends across like
you said the different
criteria for diagnosis or the different
definitions of certain symptoms across
across the world and now that we're
seeing that that
is possible and that is feasible that's
um
now there are efforts uh there's uh to
to answer see if we can try and answer
the next questions is
like what why would some people respond
to certain treatments and not others
what does that treatment
you know do to the brain and i think
that will open the door for
um clinical trials and more
translational
clinical work you mentioned mega
analyses uh you know pooling not just
the
derived metrics but uh actually going
and getting the actual scans and doing a
big combined
massive analysis what sort of resources
would you expect
or maybe you're experienced with needing
in order to carry out those kind of
analyses is this like a cloud
only based thing that you can only like
send it to amazon for uh
if you can you do this on your laptop
you know what do you need
so it depends on the type of mega
analysis so i think by mega i don't
necessarily mean
the scan as a whole but it could even be
the derived features the the meta was
more
the statistics but the mega could be
like just
having hippocampal volume across all the
individuals so
i think a lot of people have been making
proposals based on their resources right
if they don't have the
computational ability to have ten
thousand
full uh sets of diffusion imaging then
that's not what they're gonna work with
um but yeah
i think this this network and the trust
and then the also the push
from the funding um bodies in some
countries and not others
to share data um has really helped sort
of drive
some of these mega uh analytical
approaches
which is kind of brings me to my kind of
last question i was very interested in
your comments on this
is you mean enigma is this fine example
of
team science in action writ large and
i'm curious what sort of
lessons learned you might be able to
share with
you know us about you know how it's how
it's gone like what's going right
what are the strengths what are the
weaknesses or maybe room for
improvement in um you know big scale
team science like this so i think
um i think you have to go in
you know making your proposal knowing
that it's going to take a lot longer to
do
the uh the work uh then
you think um
there's the bottleneck is always gonna
be the slowest person to respond
um and the person to send the data
wrong or or maybe not in the correct
format that you asked
and i think what it has um
has really uh helped us understand
some um some common errors that we look
for so
if we uh you know um
say all right everyone code
um you know certain group of patients as
one
and the control is a zero there might be
some group that will do it the other way
so how can we check for that um using
stats or
or different different profiles um
males and females were one which had
been coded
uh one way in one group and then another
way in the rest of the groups and we
were able to
look for mean trends in um
in intracranial volume to to correct to
to
understand that the coding had been
mismatched
so i think knowing that you
have to have another level of quality
control
when you're doing these these pooled
analyses
um is i think has been
a benefit because it uh provides
more assurance that what we're what
we're doing is
uh meaningful and has hopefully less
noise
than it would otherwise um
and uh yeah i think
i think we've all learned over the past
year that
a lot of this you don't have to do
research with the people
you know in an office next door to you
but you really are
able to work um with people all over the
world and
it's just as easy as working with people
um
at the same university so um yeah i
think we
we've perfected zoom way before most
people had heard of it
you're early adopters yeah meta johann
shot thank you
so very much for sharing uh your work
with us and
all the interesting things you guys are
doing in team science and meta-analysis
and uh full genome-wide association
studies in neural imaging
uh super exciting very pioneering work
and uh thank you and all your team
members for uh
do the work that you guys are doing um i
want to thank everybody who tuned in
today
and uh we'll look forward to seeing you
next week thanks everybody have a good
weekend